what is the Neuroscience of evidence say
around why journaling is legit at the
very minimum it's like a download of
your emotions you know any emotions
negative thoughts unfinished tasks if
you keep them in your brain body system
by just thinking about them in your mind
then you actually increase your cortisol
levels and cortisol correlates with
stress if you speak it out loud write it
out into a journal or do physical
exercise and literally sweat out some of
that cortisol then you're releasing
those negative emotions negative thought
patterns anxieties worries about the
future from your brain body system if
you go back and read over your Journal
you see your thought process laid out in
front view you see your patterns of
behavior you see like your decision
making you see what you've written about
your relationships with people seeing
that in your own handwriting knowing
that it's your words and what you've
thought and what you've said you can't
run away from that so it can be like so
insightful and enlightening hey friends
thank you so much for watching if you
enjoyed this clip then click here for
the full unedited episode and if you
like that then do please consider
subscribing to the channel it means a
lot thank you so much and have a great
day bye